MOONLIT BESHIMOV:
My name is Moonlit.
AUDIENCE: Woo!
Woo!
[LAUGHTER]
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: I'm a partner
development manager at Google
Play, specializing in games.
I am keenly aware that I am
one of the last two things
standing between
you and Happy Hour.
So let's look at something fun.
What are some of the
recent trends in innovation
in mobile gaming,
specifically, genre mashing
and subscriptions?
You probably noticed
my cheerleading squad
sitting here.
We're lucky to have
Lauren, Chris, and Charles
from three of our top
partners join me on stage.
You'll hear from
each one of them
their stories of innovation.
But first, let me set the stage.
Today, we'll cover
these three things.
First, I'll give you an
overview of the global trends
around genre mashing
within mobile gaming.
Second, we'll show you
that this trend is not
limited to just mashing games.
Our three guests
here will show you
how they took genre
mashing beyond gaming
by bringing in three very
different industries.
And last, we'll
touch on a little bit
of monetization innovation
recently, namely subscriptions
in mobile gaming.
All right, let's talk about
genre mashing within gaming.
The idea of combining
multiple core game
loops into the same
game on mobile,
it's not a recent phenomenon.
In 2012, GungHo swept
the world with launch
of "Puzzle" and "Dragons,"
the godfather of puzzle RPG.
Then in 2014, "Summoners
War" by Com2uS
kickstarted the era of CC
RPG or card collecting RPG.
It also kickstarted the era of
long acronyms in mobile gaming.
So consider this a
forewarning for the amount
of acronyms I'm going to use
in the next five minutes.
Today, genre mashing
happens all over the world
in mobile gaming, from
the most casual, to core,
to beyond gaming.
Next, I'll share with you
some testimonies and case
studies from the top mobile game
developers around the world.
On the more casual end,
we have Rodeo Stampede--
an endless runner game
with builder meta.
Featherweight, the
Australian developer,
with Yodo1, the
Chinese publisher,
used genre mashing as
a way to differentiate,
turning something
that would have
been a subtle twist into
something much more unique.
The game-- this innovation--
has won them multiple awards
and helped the game
go viral globally.
"Gardenscapes" is probably one
of the most iconic successes
of genre mashing
in mobile gaming.
Playrix, the Russian
game developer,
see genre mashing as a way
to stand out from the crowded
and established market.
Something we also observed
earlier in Emily's talk
on de-risking your launch.
Playrix brilliantly
interweaves two core games
their core audience loves--
match-3 and builder.
The result is incredible player
love, loyalty, and growth.
The game is top grossing
globally, including Asia.
Now, moving on to
value more core--
"Castle Crush" by TFG, a
Brazilian game developer,
combined the elements
of combat strategy game
with that of traditional
trading card game--
kind of like "Magic,
the Gathering."
The game only launching
June this year,
and it already has more
than 5 million installs,
with a 4.5-star rating.
"Lords Mobile" is a
real-time MMO strategy
game with the colorful
elements of an RPG.
IGG, the game developer,
sees genre mashing
as a way to meet the
demand of their users
for more sophisticated games.
They also see it as a way
to bring a new experience
for users who might otherwise
not try a different genre.
"Magic Rush" by Moonton
Elex, Chinese developer
and publisher, is a fresh
combination of three genres.
Moonton created "Magic Rush"
as a global entry point.
By studying user pattern
and demand around the globe,
they learned that RPG
has been popular in Asia,
whereas combat strategy
games perform really
well in Europe and America.
So "Magic Rush"
was born as the way
to improve upon
the elements of RPG
with the swipe action
of tower defense games
and the social appeal of SLG.
But enough talking
about mashing games.
I'm going to turn it over
to my guest speakers, who
will share with you
how they reinvented fun
by mashing gaming with three
very different industries.
First, we'll hear
from Pocket Gems
about "Episode
Interactive," a game that's
turning into a new
medium for storytelling.
And then we'll have
Crowdstar to tell you
about their recent hit,
"Design Home," which
presents mobile game as a canvas
for design and creativity.
And last, we'll
hear from Workshop
about how they're
turning mobile gaming
into a new channel for music.
These are my star presenters.
First, let's welcome Lauren
Luke from Pocket Gems.
[APPLAUSE]
LAUREN LUKE: Thanks, Moonlit.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Lauren.
I'm with Pocket Gems.
Storytelling is at the
core of what we do.
One of the games I'm going
to be talking about today
is "Episode."
So storytelling
itself isn't new.
It's evolved over the course
of thousands of years.
It's crossed cultures,
generations, continents,
and it's existed in
many complex forms.
And when we look at it's
modern-day shape, what
we're looking at right now is
storytelling in mobile games.
Episode is the world's
largest network
for stories created on mobile.
Right now, we have 73,000
stories with four billion
episodes viewed.
We started back in 2014 as
a format for story building
that was built from the
ground up for mobile.
This format is still
in its very early days,
which is very
clear when you look
at other forms of
modern storytelling
like television and movies.
Episode is built
for mobile, meaning
that it has a portrait format.
It allows for
bite-sized consumption,
and it's user-driven.
You can think of it as
Snapchat meets Netflix.
Like Snapchat, it's an
interactive entertainment
built for mobile.
Like Netflix, Episode is home to
a network of Hollywood caliber
stories.
We've been inspired by
both novels and comics.
Our stories are interactive
and also animated,
but we're not limited
by print technology.
We've also drawn from
television and movies.
We have engaging stories--
sometimes, even spun
by Hollywood writers.
But users control
their own pace and how
they engage with the story.
Episode is loved by a
mobile-only generation, which
is comprised largely
of Generation Z, which
is just now coming of age.
In a survey that we did
of 36,000 people aged 13
through 25 in the US, we found
that for women 13 through 25,
14% are using their phones
for more than 12 hours a day,
11% are somehow checking
their phones in the shower,
and of those age
13 through 17, 12%
check their phones
every few seconds.
So mobile now needs
a native format
to address how this generation
interacts with real stories.
This is a group that's grown-up
entirely with smartphones,
meaning that they have
always actively participated
in how they receive
their entertainment.
So whether it's sending
snaps to friends,
going climbing with VR, or
watching a video on Musically,
they expect their
entertainment to be
both interactive and visual.
We've also been working with
a handful of IP partners.
As Hollywood has
taken successful books
and made them into legendary
film franchises, such as Harry
Potter and Twilight,
Episode is now
the first to take great
TV and movie franchises
and bring them
natively to mobile.
In 2015, we partnered
with Paramount
to bring "Mean
Girls" to episode.
In 2016, we worked with our
friends over at Warner Brothers
to release "Pretty
Little Liars."
And this year, we're thrilled
to be working with Universal
to introduce "Pitch Perfect"
on mobile to the world.
So this will be out in
the next few months--
keep an eye open for it.
And with these
franchise launches,
Episode has begun to establish
itself as an industry model,
bringing fans the
ability to actually
be part of stories that
have these cult followings.
As YouTube's led to
the rise of streamers,
and Snapchat's given way to a
new kind of social celebrity,
Episode has also formed
a new class of creators.
We've shared our
storytelling tools
and made them available
to all who are in Episode.
Episode creators
are now building
their own long-form
narrative stories.
Right now, we have over
eight million creators
who are telling their own
stories within the app.
And there are five million
weekly active users
who are reading Episode
original stories
as well as these Hollywood
inspired stories.
So as we continue
to build Episode,
we are thinking constantly,
not only of the stories
that we're bringing to the
world but of this community
of storytellers.
And we're thrilled to be part
of this special and unique
opportunity to help
give storytellers
both a platform and a voice.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Next up, we've got
Chris from Crowdstar.
CHRIS MCGILL: Thanks, Lauren.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Chris.
I'm the GM of "Design Home."
I'm super excited to be here.
I want to thank Moonlit.
I want to thank Cliff.
I want to thank Emily
for the opportunity.
And Google has been an
unbelievable partner to us.
We're a little different,
and they've really gotten us,
and I super appreciate it.
Well, "Design Home" is a
3D interior design game.
It's essentially an endless
dollhouse but for grown-ups.
And before I talk
about "Design Home,"
I want to talk a little
bit about the philosophy
of the studio I work
for called Crowdstar.
Because Crowdstar has
actually been mashing up
reality-based design
games for five years,
first with the hit "Covet
Fashion" in the fashion
space, which after five years
is still going very strong,
and now with "Design
Home," which we
launched about 11 months ago.
And to be honest with you,
Crowdstar was born in a moment
of desperation-- or at
least the current iteration
of Crowdstar--
when they realized
that they had better
do something different
and something bold,
or they were going to
die a certain death.
And what they did, and I
wasn't there at the time,
is really look for
the white space.
And what they found was
there was a huge segment
of people that were totally
under-served by the gaming
market in something that
not only would enthrall them
but also would help
them in their real life.
And that segment was women--
not girls but women.
And they have a
different mindset really.
These are women who are coming
into their own financially.
They are highly engaged,
highly creative.
They often are
focused on somebody--
on people that aren't always
themselves, namely families.
And this is a creative
canvas for them
to not only express
their creativity
but apply it to real life.
And it's a positive sum game.
We always make sure it
is a positive sum game.
OK, so what do we do?
Well, we partner
with real brands.
We model real products, and
we put them into 3D settings.
We're essentially
changing the conversation
between makers and consumers,
so that makers aren't just
talking at consumers.
We're giving the
consumers a chance
to play with products
in a fun atmosphere,
and it always comes with links,
so that you can buy things
in the real world.
So for example, we
have dozens and dozens
of real furniture partners.
Some bigs, and we also go
and find niche boutiques.
And to date, we've
modeled 6,700 products,
and that grows every single day.
It's a very simple game loop.
It's shop, design, win.
It opens up a world
of content experiences
that you just can't do, you
can't do in your own home.
You get to mix and match and
visualize completed designs
in a way that mood boards
could never duplicate.
We launch five challenges--
hand-crafted challenges--
a day.
They stay open for three days.
And once you're done with
your design, you submit it,
and it gets scored,
frankly, by the audience.
So it goes in and other
people vote on what's good
and what's not.
You get back your score.
You get virtual prizes.
So everybody is happy.
And then you also see
what the winning designs
were, the highest
score so that you
can see what you might have done
better or what goes with what.
So there's always a
learning experience.
And it's a mixture of
highly relatable settings,
whether it's a suburban
house in Erie, Pennsylvania,
to an apartment in New York,
to aspirational settings
like a tropical island.
And then we have some
fantasy settings.
So you could be
designing a moonbase.
Or like at Christmastime,
one of my personal favorites
was you did the interior
of a gingerbread house.
It's simple, and it's fun.
But it turns out that modeling
reality is really hard,
and I'm blessed to work with
some incredible producers,
engineers, and artists
because the standards that you
have to reach to model
reality are really high.
These are not
stylized characters
running around a screen.
You have to figure
out, not only model
the furniture and
the decor perfectly,
but the room has to fit.
You have to figure
out the lighting.
You have to figure out the
shadows and how everything
is going to go together when
you have thousands of products
that the user might use.
So, and then you have to also
run a handcrafted live ops,
which is just really intense.
And again, I'm super
blessed with the people
that I work with.
And while we're happy
with the aesthetics now,
you can imagine where
this space is going.
I mean our objective is to be
able to fall into the room--
to taste the air in the room.
And with AR, VR, and lots
of other possible Rs coming,
it's a pretty exciting
and dynamic space.
I'm enthralled on
really where it can go.
So, so far, we were
launched in November 15th.
So we're coming up on
our one year birthday.
Through June, which is
what I can talk about now
that we're a publicly
traded company because we
were acquired by Glu, we've
had 25 million downloads.
We've exceeded a
million users every day.
We've done a little more
than $40 million in bookings.
But I think really the
most interesting thing
is that our users are
generating more than 2 million
handcrafted rooms a day.
We've built a house of
over 500 million rooms.
I think we're just
getting started.
And thanks for your time.
I'll buy you a drink
at the bar if--
later.
MOONLIT BESHIMOV: Now,
you've heard from Workshop
how they're thinking about
their subscription design.
I want to also share with
you some best practices.
There are two main ways
of using subscription
in your mobile games.
One, we have subscription VIP.
Two, we have subscription IAP.
I promise I'm not going to rap.
Subscription VIP-- it's all
about the high-value users.
These users are
motivated by prestige,
vanity, loyalty rewards.
So your goal as a developer
is to really increase
long-term retention,
total revenue,
the loyalty from the payers
and also other players.
Some examples of
subscription VIP design
include exclusive
and/or early access
to special content,
specific and special promos
for these subscribers, and
also higher daily caps.
For subscription
IAP, you should be
thinking about targeting
everybody else--
but especially, the non-buyers.
These people are motivated by
getting a good financial deal.
So your goal as a developer
is to really increase
buyer retention and cultivate
the habit of logging in daily
to increase your LTV.
So some example of
subscription IAP design
include having a SKU
of gems that pay out
over several periods of time--
several days, for example.
This will help
players come back in
and log in daily to
claim the rewards.
As with all subscription
and monetization design,
really keep track
of the downsides.
Be careful of
cannibalization, and keep
a close pulse of your pillar of
sentiment among your community.
Now, talking about trends
and innovations fun,
I also want to leave
you with something
to take with you as you
head into Happy Hour
after the next session.
So let's summarize.
Genre mashing should be used
for, one, differentiation,
or two, as a new way
to consume content.
Subscriptions should be used
for, one, VIP to identify VIP,
to encourage engagement,
to increase loyalty.
And subscription
IAP should be used
to offer a good deal for
people who might otherwise not
spend in your games.
Now, thank you,
and thanks, Lauren.
Thanks, Charles and Chris for
an amazing talk and sharing
with us your experience.
Let's give them a
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]